[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
developer for devotees the new
developers of the terrible overkill the
lords have had their eyes on this if you
don't mind let's get right into it yeah
two things so uh we've tucked it into a
level that's about
the beginning of episode two which is
coming out in october
we have a demo in here
the difficulty is a little bit too much
yeah
um
so for those who don't have any idea
what turbo overkill is can you please
tell all audiences around
what is terminal good thing it's uh
basically being my dream project i grew
up playing german a lot of first places
and i wanted to make a game
my dream game would be especially
calling all these different greats
for one match um so turbo kills a
cyberpunk tutor
highly focused on the smart phase
combat
yeah awesome
so basically an ai called speaking over
the planet and uh it started making it
cyborg
sitting down to the planet to clean up
the place so we're here to handle
business and cleanse
okay yeah so this is uh this is when
stuff goes really well and basically you
can see the ais will start taking over
and
it has gone bad gone very
very frenetic already oh yeah wait a
minute what's that grandpa look at you
that's the grappler girl tell me about
this grappler so
ah
that's crazy uh this gun is one of the
new ones we have uh it's got a microwave
theme like home
it makes popcorn
i love the bits i love the detail to the
bits it's a bit of a meme but i felt
like i just had to put that in there i
love it i love the girl browser so as
far as the engine what engine are we
talking about this is uh this is unity
yeah it's uh
i mean online it says i'm real but it's
actually unity it's actually kind of
like we got we got the exclusive here
first yeah yeah um
yeah it's um sort of something i mean
i've been using since 2013
also
very very
intuitive for you exactly yeah
i'm mostly self-taught programming so i
just followed up youtube
and i mean learning unity was pretty
easy because wow
self-taught you now here's the thing how
long has it been as far as from a
development standpoint for you being
self-taught like that's extremely
impressive yeah it's um this is my first
commercial project um i have worked on
these
so as far as like levels again i'm
noticing the verticality i'm noticing
it's reversing
the effects look absolutely amazing very
visceral in your face running gun combat
oh yeah as far as like
levels as far as like are we seeing
bosses in this do we have those
encounters or is it this is just like
fast breaks phonetic level the level
combat yeah so there is a oh god
that's amazing um
that's the beauty of
development
yeah so episode 2 has a lot more a lot
more story involved
see there are these bouncy hunters that
are hunting them down basically you're
seeing this planet to take care of the
problem but as you can see things have
gone bad
so
yeah very bad so basically the people
that hired you to clean up the place
they have assumed that you have been
consumed by the virus that have taken
over the planet do they sit down about
them
come get you um
where
you know you're fighting against these
bosses they kind of play like a uh a
quick different bot or something so they
have the same move sets that you have uh
they give all that make your grandfather
yeah
they're more smarter than your average
ai and the game
yeah mostly they're just like
yeah
yeah so so you could tell when one of
these bounty killers have kind of
entered the playing field yeah based on
the reaction and the ai okay yeah and it
also you know there are a few as well so
it's a few story elements but it was
important for me to make sure like i
don't want to fog people down the story
i just want him to get free to be active
so you know a lot of the interactions
with these things
that's my face that's my feet
so this is more like
fun focus just fun gun [ __ ] was that
kind of get this position it was yeah
like i get frustrated the whole hell
when i play a game
um
i get frustrated go hell when i play a
game and just like i just
like i just want to get in and start
shooting stuff guys i had no friends
like that and as soon as the narrative
comes up they're skipping skipping
skipping let's get to the action
um
right
[Music]
[Music]
i don't want to
and i appreciate that you're actually
changing
um
[Music]
um
is
uh
customization
especially like i started playing the
game
video games and
it was important for me it's like okay
if i started like yeah
um
nice
but i mean it does work right now but
it's not especially not verified yet
yeah
get this man a steam deck please
um
um
it's
still very early days
overkill peace
[Music]